this is big a colossal win in hartlepool
for the conservatives and boris johnson
another blue brick in what used to be
labour's red wall
and the tories are building right across
the country
a normal-sized boss man here too he
thinks he knows what voters want
i think what the this uh election shows
is that
people want a party in a government that
is focused on them focused on
delivering change and that's what uh
jill has been campaigning on and that's
why i
i go on uh beth about the advantages of
the things that wedding you said in the
2019 after the 2019 elections people in
the red wall had lent you
their vote do you think now something
else is happening this is a deeper shift
is that your hope well i hope that i
think what i think what happened in in
2019 was that people
mandated us to get brexit done and to
begin the process of uniting and
leveling up
and i think that what's happened now is
they can see we did get brexit done
and to a certain extent they can see
that we delivered on that
and i think what people want us to do
now is to get on
with delivering on everything else
eleven years into power the
conservatives still
eating into labor's territory
win in northumberland in the north east
dudley redditch and uneaten in the west
midlands
ben halchen the conservative party
candidate
is duly elected as mayor for the tease
valley
combined authority thank you
and holding the tease valley marity with
an increased margin
places labour was supposed to be
fighting back
these defeats really hurt none more so
than in hartley pool
people here had voted labour for over
six decades but no
more boris johnson's brexit dividend is
still
paying out not just here but across the
country
from northumberland to nuneaton the
conservative vote share went up the most
in areas that voted decisively to leave
votes lent in 2019 now being freely
given
but it suggests something more than just
brexit 2
something more profound about the
redrawing of our political map
over the past couple of decades working
class voters have gradually turned
away from labour england has gradually
turned blue in all but our major cities
while in scotland people have turned to
the snp
and it all leaves labour at a loss
whilst the pm tours new conservative
territory for the labour leader
nowhere to go but the office i'm
basically disappointed in the results
um and you know i take full
responsibility
for the results and i will take full
responsibility
for fixing things we have changed
as a party but we haven't set out a
strong enough case
to the country very often we've been
talking to ourselves instead of to the
country
and we've lost the trust of working
people particularly in places like
hartley paul
i intend to do whatever is necessary
to fix that but not everyone in the
labour party agrees on what the fix is
suck here now under pressure to do
things very differently
it's a pretty disastrous result it's one
that we were expecting
and really kia now has to learn lessons
from us he has to
reset the button press the reset button
so that he can go back
to the very issues that he was elected
to lead the labour party on which were
radical policies
kirsten has always said he could turn
around labour's fortunes in time for the
next election
but that journey yet to even get going
these results
cause for real alarm